[Music]
all right so let's shift away from a
little bit of the horse race politics up
there just some broader themes so the
free speech stuff you have been in the
thick of this I mean yeah it's gonna
morning truly truly in the thick of this
you get protested at pretty much every
day
when's the last time you're at a
university that you weren't protesting I
mean I would say half the universities I
go try well yeah protested I mean I go
to a lot of universities I've spoken at
ten in the last two months I would sigh
guess I only hear about the one right
you only see the headlines about the
ones where they're heavy protests yeah
attentive maybe a third of them I get
heavy protests okay so about a third of
them you're getting heavy protests now I
would venture to say the prepper one
that's listen to this interview so far
whether they agree with you or not you
don't seem to be a hate monger or sort
of white supremacist or Jewish
supremacist or some other naughty
related something or other act like okay
what are these people thinking what do
you really think is going on for these
people cuz it's a lot of misguided
nonsense and and I forget UCLA with Milo
which the whole separate crowd they in
your crowd obviously uh but they're
protesting him too yeah I mean I think
that the for the most part people I
don't assume my own level of notoriety
so I think most people are protesting
they've never heard anything that I've
said anything that I've written right
there's no idea they know liar they go
exactly when I was at Wisconsin like one
of the things that a lot of the Flyers
come out and the Flyers put like the
most provocative title they can to get
people to come right on and and usually
that and they're they're fine but it's
but uh for example Wisconsin I had
people getting up and chanting a guy
right at the beginning stand up and say
something about how I was enabling
Hitler and I was like dude you see the
yarmulke like what what are you even
talking about what are you talking about
and then they're chanting they were
chanting F white supremacy at mazing
I've been spending this entire election
cycle under assault from white
supremacists right because I told them
that they that they're wrong and I think
that they're evil and the end
I mean you are quite literally the
number one online target of the all
right all right yeah exactly yeah and
and so but I'm getting protested by by
the by the BLM crowd and so it's I think
that it comes from ignorance I think it
comes from this place where any opposing
view must be attacked and we don't even
have to do our research we don't have to
try and debunk it
it's a bunking it actually take
effort going and yelling about it
doesn't take any effort at all and
that's why whenever I do these lectures
the first thing I do when we do Q&A is I
say if you disagree with me you get to
go first all people who disagree go to
the front of the line
and it's and because that's always more
interesting and I treat the people who
disagree with me actually with respect
if you're not if you're not yelling at
me and you're not flipping me off and
shouting F white supremacy I'm happy to
treat you with respect and have a civil
discussion I do it all the time and
that's the one you can win over right
exactly
in a way it's it's selfishly rewarding
for you because that's the guy who's on
the fence that might come to your side
or at the very least we can have a
discussion where the person gives a
point I get the counterpoint now all the
whole audience is smarter for it the
audience is not smarter for having these
people chance and stand in front of the
stage and try to disrupt an event and me
right morons on the chalkboard behind
them I mean it's fun for me and I think
it's fun for the crowd but it's not but
it's not informative in any way except
to show that there are these people who
are out there yeah how's it feel just
just on the personal level when this
stuffs happening because there are
threats I mean again when I was a
usually there was a bomb threat people
bashing on the door seemed like they
were coming in screaming like we didn't
know by you know anything violent could
happen like oh that's up like just on a
purely personal note you're a person
you're relatively new father I think
like yeah I've got two kids in three
years yeah okay so just on that note
like putting yourself out there like
that what do you make of that uh well I
mean I don't tell my wife about it
she's about on to I know she was not on
Twitter she does not do the Facebook
thing right off everything yeah exactly
like she's she's kind of protected from
it I have I feel like I'm usually the
safest person in the room I'm the only
got there were security right so I've
got my own private security that we
contract to do these things the first
time we did it I was like why are we
even doing this and turned out that was
Cal State LA and there's like an actual
riot there so it's so yeah now I've got
security guys who come with me
I'm always relieved when it's not that
because again I would much prefer to
have just a normal like I'm not looking
for the the I really am not looking for
the headline that says protesters come
in Shapiro finishes protesters or
whatever like that honestly that's easy
for me it's not hard like these people
have a combined IQ in single digits it's
not difficult to make stupid people look
stupid it's more difficult to actually
have a conversation with somebody who
has a point of view and some facts to
back them up it's more interesting but
you know as far as the person will say
the aspect of it uh I it doesn't it
doesn't have to meet your physical
safety as much as just sort of your men
mostly puzzled me I'm like what why like
what am I sit like I'm here preaching
decency and non identity group politics
and I'm getting protested for that they
have people yelling at me and
threatening violence because of that
right I could understand if I were
coming here and I was saying something
that that's you know actively calling
for violence or something or even
implying that violence is okay in any
way but half of my speeches are about
why violence is never okay right like
you don't get to hit people if you
disagree with them and then to prove my
point they come and they try and hit
people who disagree with them it's it's
so bizarre right where were you with
with Christina Hoff Sommers I doesn't -
Paul yeah that would Paul which - Paul
is banned by lo and writin a the boy
lied and Milo and then they immediately
banned me on top of that right like I
was even their way and then first of all
this is absurd they banned Milo like
everybody knows about the disagreements
that I have with my low but it's absurd
Milo getting banned from campuses I'm
sure makes Milo really happy because the
headline but right but it's but it's
just it's stupidity of the highest order
if you disagree with him go into bunk
him if you disagree them don't show up I
mean that'd be the worst thing you can
do to Milo it's just not show up for
this lecture but it's it but the you
know they banned me on top of that
DePaul and then they didn't even give it
like their only excuse was the security
and I was like you can't control your
own students that's not my fault that's
your fault your university should be
doing that and then you can go view the
video they actually we announced that
Kristina was gonna be speaking there and
I was going to you know accompany her
and they wouldn't let me in the building
as guests they wouldn't let me in the
building as a member of her team and
they wouldn't let me in the building
just sit in the audience what are they
saying to you at that time are they
saying because their people are
threatening violence like well no there
were no threats of violence how was
amazing at the pollak we walked up and
the whole day they've been telling my
security team that if Shapiro shows up
that we're going to arrest him if she
shows up that we will literally land at
the airport late for trespass okay right
so that would be the crime is
trespassing on their campus they
literally went out and got a sheriff
from Cook County to sit there to
facilitate the the transfer of arrest if
the campus police arrest you they have
to have somebody from from the county
actually because they actually you have
the guy sitting there in the law no
protesters anywhere none right I mean
it's 30 police officers and security
guards and me yeah and I walk up and I
was like really like I can [ __ ] like
sofa and I said you know if I take two
steps for are you going to arrest me
the guy said yeah any giant yeah people
like you should get arrested well you
know at that point I'm really not so hot
on spending the evening in a Cook County
prison like that's a Cook County Jail
for the for the stand up your beliefs
but not to the point about that night
well again like it again they actually
have the right to arrest me it's a
private university the Republic
University I would walk if your private
or public university I woulda made them
arrest me at a private university they
do have the they do have the legal right
to to ban whoever they want it just
demonstrates how ridiculous they are
that they're willing to arrest me yeah
and the fact again that they're taking
everyone from you to Milo it's like
that's showing real intolerance because
it's not just a solid it's not just an
idea it's people that disagree wildly on
things exactly well they accept accept
if they are remotely construed as
right-wing right so if you're if you're
in if you're a terrorist convicted in
Israel you can speak it they have one
speak in 2014 I think and Paul so if you
so you have to be within a certain
spectrum but they they refuse to even
acknowledge a spectrum right
although DePaul actually did write to
Paul - Paul came out later and they and
they tried to distinguish kind of what I
say from a Mylo says which is kind of
interesting but that didn't change their
behavior enough to actually let me speak
yeah all right so let's let's just do
the Maya thing quick I don't want to
dwell on it but but so many people ask
so for the record are you sitting here
right now I will police say what I've
said many times on Twitter which is that
Milo had the original idea of init he
sent an email to our team said let's do
this debate me and Bend able moderate
you immediately responded yes you gave
dates and then Milo basically dipped out
that says the truth as much as I know it
is exactly right and so that's exactly
right until and then went around the
country proclaiming that I had chickened
out and and trying to drive this rivalry
with me that I could not care less about
like Milo I wish nothing but success to
- Milo based on the good things he does
I hope nothing but failure for him for
bad things that does just like anybody
else right over and it's and you know as
in you know I'm not gonna play Lucy in
the football with him mean he ducked out
he chickened out and and I mean look the
fact is that even the fact I was willing
to do in the first place after he was
tweeting pictures of me
a black baby on the day that my son was
born become a [ __ ] no I it was bit
generous but then now that I'm not gonna
play that game that's not my game
and the thing is I genuinely like both
of you and I think we could have done
something really good I have Milo's
coming back in in February I think that
my guess is that the ground the ground
is a little too scorch
yeah I'm not interested but yeah yeah
again I'm not interested in doing
Charlie Brown Lucy routine so that he
can go around the country proclaiming
that he's brave after having chickened
out yeah and for the record when he
comes in in February I'll say the exact
same thing damn it he can say we
shouldn't yeah that's fine that that's
why um I really very sophisticated
British sir yeah all right thing now I
have done a couple videos on the alright
my general feeling although I think
something is changing now the Trump is
in power is that for the months leading
up to the election this was mostly a
bunch of [ __ ] posters it was mostly a
bunch of anonymous 4chan and reddit
people it was not really white
supremacists and neo-nazis there were
some of these people in the mix of it
yet but it was just people who were home
in their basements or wherever that were
tweeting at people in power media people
apologies yeah to upset everybody to get
them retweeted to get everyone to show
I'm such a victim look at me look what's
happening to me online I'm sober and
basically what I've said is if we deal
with some of these issues honestly like
immigration or ism ism or something
that's how we'll defang some of the
rhetoric around all this stuff so I
think there's truth to that now I think
it's it's starting to shift a little bit
now that that Trump won the election
right now I think I think there's truth
that so what I've distinguished in
interviews where I talked about this is
the alt-right philosophers and
promulgate errs and my laws are probably
had or of the alt-right and he denies it
but he likes to play the clown nose off
clown nose off routine clown nose on
clown nose off routine with the
alt-right yes I'm not I'm not really a
member of the alright I just write
stories giving their expressing their
viewpoints on huh but it's but the the
piece that he wrote for for Breitbart
about the alt-right is a really
definitive piece about what the alt
right is and I think that for the most
part it's pretty accurate there the
alt-right philosophy is a lot of people
consider themselves alright are not
technically alright they are as you say
should posters right they're people who
have been drawn in by the idea that
they're being politically incorrect and
they're violating taboos and it's kind
of fun to do that it's very teenager II
and all this kind of stuff
the people who are actually
our choral writers people who Milo knows
their philosophy and he talked about it
in that piece right the people the
Richard Spencer's and the Jared Taylor's
and all those group those people out our
actual honest-to-god white supremacist
and there's a line in that piece where
he talks about about civil as Western
civilization being inseparable from
ethnicity which is white supremacy
that's right that is definitional white
supremacy so it's so that's the
philosophy but a lot of people consider
themselves alright have been dragged
into that by people who have been
inaccurate in their definitions of the
alright so instead of just saying okay
there's the the people who actually
believe this white supremacist crap and
then they're a bunch of people who are
just posting stupid stuff online to get
a rise out of people they conflate the
two and then what's even worse is that
you get people who are legit you know
conservatives who don't know what the
alright is and so they assume that
everybody who is anti-establishment is
alright and so that gives them a number
that they don't actually hold right the
number of people who are definitely who
are really alright like people who
actually believe in white nationalism or
white superiority that's a really small
number of people it really is and then
they've built themselves out they've
kind of built this this there's the
there's the core and then there's the
chaff they've built this kind of large
chaff sphere around themselves and one
of the I think tasks we have is to try
and separate the core from the chaff and
say okay you know all you people who are
anti-establishment
listen I'm anti-establishment too I
think Mitch McConnell is terrible I was
not a fan of Paul Ryan but that's not
the same thing as being alright and so
you know what I'm fearful of is the
winks and nods to the actual alright
like I think when I say winks and nods
and I've been saying this for a while
like when Donald Trump was on TV and
who's asked about the KKK so I don't KKK
I've never heard of them what are you
talk
okay like we all know that you've heard
the KKK we all know you've heard of
David Duke your your microphone didn't
malfunction you were you'd like it was
two days before the Louisiana primary
and you didn't want to alienate voters
who thought you were going to win in the
Louisiana primary right that's that's
what was going on there that was that
was a wink and a nod right when Donald
Trump was retweeting white white
nationalist accounts right when he's
when he's granting you know legitimacy
to some kind of I wouldn't say fully
alt-right figures but people who are
very popular with the alt-right the Alex
Jones crowd that's that's the kind of
stuff where you're getting into kind of
a gray area but
the do I do I think they're an upward
mortally mobile threats I think no
because I think their philosophy is so
repugnant that most people the vast
majority people think that's stupid
but I think it's easy to sucker people
into thinking they're all right and the
game there is if you sucker people into
thinking they're all right and then
people like me attack the alt-right
then they go oh he must be attacking me
so I'm not attacking you okay so you
post a Pepe meme like okay so I think
you're stupid but I don't think you're
all right
mmm right I think the day but as I said
before on your show and I got a lot of
flack for it if you tweeted me something
that's indistinguishable from David Duke
it's not my responsibility to determine
your motive like it's a tweet I'm gonna
treat that the same way that I treated
tweet from David Duke it's an idiotic
tweet from an idiotic person so how much
of this then is just related to the
internet culture in general so when I
saw the was it Spencer and DC you come
you know and the hi on PA okay so I've
had family members on both sides my
dad's side and my mom's side died in the
Holocaust back to you probably did as
well so I don't take kindly to that in
any way
I don't like it I'd rather not see
neo-nazis and all of that stuff however
I saw that and my thought was these are
two hundred losers and unfortunately
we've now the media will now run this
it'll be on CNN all day long everyone
will keep talking about a talking about
talking about people tell me all the
time talk about it talk about it more
yeah and it's like all we're doing is
inflating this thing that these people
have always existed hate is always going
to exist I can't make every person my
great black people I can't make every
person not a Jews or gay people or
whatever I say is it's it's human nature
you may not like it but it's human
nature and I think we're inflating this
stuff I agree with that and I've argued
against sort of the inflation of it by
the same token I think that there's been
empowerment of the fellow-travellers
people who the alt-right sees is sort of
ideological forebears people like Pat
Buchanan I mentioned Alex Jones Alex
Jones probably isn't technically alright
or wouldn't consider himself the US but
when he talks about Jewish influence in
the media in his rants
he's obviously granting them a lot of
kind of credibility and and he's giving
them some cement ammunition to feel like
they have allies there are a lot of
people who seem to be okay with with
benefiting from the [ __ ] posters in the
end the alt-right groups if they can
gain traffic that was my main critique
of Breitbart by the way like when I said
that Steve Danon was appealing
all right that's because he called
himself a plat Breitbart a platform for
the all right and the idea was that he
was and this is always been my critique
of Steve and the left doesn't understand
anything remotely approaching moderation
so my critique of Steve and Breitbart
was always that what had happened was
that Breitbart had been moved in
direction what they're willing to pander
to some of the worst people on earth by
posting material that appealed to those
people and and that demonstrates to me a
tremendous will for power from from
Steve and willingness to work with
anyone to get there and that's my main
critique and the left immediately sees
done oh well he must be an anti somebody
it must be a racist sounds like no as I
said I said he's not Tunis you've got
out of your way to say that you don't
think he's in it but no I don't have any
evidence at all that Steve's an
anti-semite yeah no I think he's an
[ __ ] but I don't think sees an answer
right so what do you make of that then
so you worked with the guy no you worked
he was technically your boss right sure
his chairman of the company and yeah so
he was technically your boss you have no
evidence that he's an anti-semite right
you as the as the ADL said you were the
number one attack recipient of
anti-semitic abuse online so you are
aware of the array of it for sure
and I will say again there are people
who promulgate this following so for
example when Milo is banned from Twitter
my anti-semitic feed went down 70%
immediately really oh yeah and so could
see the question so were those is where
those actual anti-semites our [ __ ]
posters I don't know like we had their
[ __ ] posters yeah is the 90% of them but
what about you but you but what you are
doing is you're mainstreaming the idea
that this sort of rhetoric is okay
because and this was always my critique
of sort of the notion that it's the same
thing to be politically incorrect as it
is to just be a bad person right like if
it like political the whole point of
fighting political correctness is so you
can say true things in order to
promulgate better ideas it's not you can
that you're not doing in the world any
good I just shout in the N word yeah
right not doing me any good of the world
any good by just tweeting people
pictures of black kids cuz you're a [ __ ]
right well how's the world become a
better place because how's the dialogue
become any better because of that you
certainly have the right to do it I'm
not arguing you don't have the right to
do it but you also have the right to
slap yourself in face of the crime
yeah you know that's it you have a lot
of the right to do lots of stupid things
the question is there are people who are
making the affirmative case that this is
making the country a better place and
making the dialogue more open when in
reality what you're actually doing is
you're breeding the resistance to the
dialogue right because the
yeah look I guess what those people
would argue is that the system has
become so rigid and so afraid of
everything and every idea that the only
way and I think Milo actually said this
to me on my show which was a year before
the election maybe that this was the
only way we were gonna break any of this
but even Milo knows he's lying next when
Milo's on ask him one question if he
thinks that's true ask him to say the
n-word on your show that's the most
rigid taboo in American society ask him
to say the n-word if he really believes
that all taboos ought to be broken
because taboos are worthy of being
broken and we have to break down the
system ask them if he has the balls
sitting on word on your show I will do
that I guarantee he says no
you